You've found a sweater
pattern that you love.
The neckline, design, and stitch pattern
are just perfect, but it's sleeveless.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I'm past the point of wanting
to show off my arms and I need sleeves.
If the pattern is a drop shoulder or basic
square armhole, you can easily add sleeves
with the Knit It Now custom sleeves tool.
Measure both your front and back armholes
from the pattern diagram or instructions.
Determine your desired sleeve length,
short sleeve, three quarter or full
length, and be sure to adjust the wrist
or arm measurement accordingly.
Choosing your custom sleeve pattern
instructions, choose to pick up and knit
the sleeves from the top down
or start at the cuff and knit up.
No more bare arms.
Make the sweater your own.